[Music]
we're just dancing to the music how cute
is that our own cooking confidence coach
nanny bubby is back in studio thanks to
chapman automotive the sponsors of this
next segment today we are learning how
to make frozen yogurt bark with fresh
berries awesome that sounds good and
refreshing it is it's great smells good
it does so you know just like during the
holidays we have uh chocolate bark right
or white chocolate bark but when it gets
spring and it gets warm like heavy
chocolate just feels too heavy okay so
as we get closer to spring i love the
colors we're getting there some days we
go back to winter but yeah
so we're going to start first with this
raspberry sauce okay okay so this is
seedless raspberry jam we're going to
start with that about a third of a cup
now does it have to be raspberry could
you strawberry yeah you could you could
absolutely if you you know take what you
can find and you know do what you can do
so we're going to put in two tablespoons
of a
fruit flavored uh
balsamic vinegar okay a little acid
about a tablespoon of lemon juice we're
going to put in lemon zest
[Music]
and pop that's it and then we're just
going to swirl it up
okay so there we go smell i wish you
could smell this
see that is not great so then we're
going to take this and well let's add
the yogurt first of course two main
ingredients okay so i'm going to give
you this because we have to spread it
out okay okay are we spreading yogurt
like butter yeah we're going to spread
yogurt like butter then we'll spread
love like butter when we're done okay so
just you take your side i'll take mine
okay unless there are techniques of this
there's no technique you're doing great
don't crash on each other yeah just well
you know there's that okay so there you
go now the next thing we'll take this
and just set it over this part's good
for the kids because i'm having a great
time i love that you are so now we're
going to swirl the raspberry sauce
through the yogurt so we're going to do
a dollop we're going to do another
dollop and then another dollop of that
and then we're going to take it and with
the tip
we're going to just you know did you
think i was going to hit you with that
no of course
oh my god you are so good oh why thank
you i i do cooking confidence classes
with me with nanny buddy that's for sure
okay even if it's just twice a week okay
so what we want to do
here's an antibody tidbit okay notice
that there is parchment paper here right
so when we do the whole 30 in january we
want to get metals out of our body right
when we do that cleanse the point of
this is that you never want to put
aluminum next to your food okay this is
an aluminum uh sheet pan so always put
parchment between the food and the
aluminum that you're using no matter
what it is
taking notes yes that is a great tip you
definitely want to do that and so that
way you don't get any toxicity into your
body so now ready i will do the
raspberries you do the strawberries
we've got blueberries here i'll take it
yeah okay we're just going to drop it in
okay and just sort of spread them around
just you know randomly there you go okay
oh my god she's throwing love into town
okay that's the creative part you know i
love that go for it girl okay and then
we're going to drop blueberries so you
just want to
take some blueberries
these fruits are your preference but you
can kind of mix it up well it was summer
what's really great because the stone
fruits are not out right now so in the
summer you can replace this with your
stone fruits if you'd like anything it's
very now you can take the chopped um
pistachios okay i almost said pimentos
pistachios and just throw them on and
we'll take just chocolate same time yep
yep
oh my gosh she's going yes wow there you
go okay and we're just shaving some
chocolate now you're going to take this
do you have a chocolate preference
dark type of chocolate dark dark
chocolate okay okay and then what we're
going to do is put it in the freezer and
through the magic of television
it comes out like this beautiful move
over to our little parfait cups
okay
here we go there you go champagne cups
champagne cup so here it is and now
we're just going to
cut it
just chop it
and under the light it just kind of gets
softer but
okay so quickly but let's see so this is
so the cup is just for decoration
obviously yeah you're just going to
serve it right we're just going to
break it ooh look at that and this is
look at that and some texture everybody
this is so good it is so take a bite
yeah take a bite it's cold so careful
with the teeth i know that feeling so
now what you want to do is you can top
it with kahlua you look at the topic
isn't it you can top it with hershey's
chocolate okay and top it with the
raspberry sauce how about bailey's irish
cream
yeah how about raspberry liqueur you got
it and this is delicious thank you
because together we're going to spread
love like butter we're going to spread
love like better check out nanny bubby's
kitchen and garden on social media and
online at nannybubby.com we also want to
thank chapman automotive for sponsoring
this segment thank you kendall